in my professional life I have always
wanted to be the best at something I
just didn't know what that was and I
wanted to push myself to try to be the
best and right now I'm in a lucky
position where you know this is the
moment I think for me where I can take
you know a three four billion dollar
balance sheet and ten exit and so how do
I do it and in doing so it's not the
money it's proving how good I could be
in these moments where I need to be
clear minded where I need to make really
good decisions where I need to manage my
psychology I'll give you an example like
as I told you like I've been trimming
where markets were down ten thousand or
thousand where markets were up a
thousand where you know and and I see
all these folks who would be like oh I
you know clipped the top and I you know
covered my shorts at the bottom and I
think wow I'm an idiot I mean I didn't
do any of those things I've just been
dollar cost averaging my way to more
liquidity and it would make me feel
insecure but I had to battle through
that and put myself in a position now
where I have an even bigger cash pile
and I can say okay I can make a couple
billion dollar bets here and try to 10x
it and in doing so I can be part of the
solution I could hire lots of people I
could you know solve really important
problems that I've always wanted to
solve and I'm putting myself to that
challenge and so I don't regret any of
it but I'm really cognizant of this line
because if I am dysfunctional at home I
will not be functional at work and if I
fail at work I need to firewall my
personal life so that I can still be
functional because it's it's this is a
moment where I've really I'm trying to
learn how to have equanimity and I think
like if you look at the best people in
work at any work they have an equanimity
to it they they are humble enough to
realize they're a participant that
they're not some all-seeing all-powerful
omnipotent presence they wait for their
moment and then they participate in a
functional way and that's a real skill I
think very few people have it Buffett
has it very few people have it speaking
of Buffett you and him are in somewhat
similar situation I think a little bit
different size and and that you have
cash on the sidelines you're being
patient you kind of understand at least
generally where we are on this cycle and
and having that patience will likely pay
off when you go to get aggressive I
think a lot of people are saying you
know when's omaha gonna move type thing
for you where are you going to look is
it public markets is it looking at kind
of more the hard text doesn't you've
been talking in the private markets is
it may be something that we aren't
expecting like real estate or other
assets kind of how do you think about
okay I've got a couple billion dollars
how do i 10x it there's a lot of risk
involved in that obviously right so how
do you kind of think through that the
way that I'm asking the question right
now is first and foremost what is not
going to change and you know there's a
bunch of things that are not going to
change meaning you're still going to go
out eventually you're still going to
travel eventually you're still going to
buy things offline eventually you'll
still you know want to make things that
will require energy eventually you'll
still need to eat you'll still need to
close yourself you'll still need access
to the Internet all what this moment is
good at doing is clarifying a hierarchy
of needs and so the first thing that
we're doing and this is for us and my
team and I a multi-week process is just
re underwriting what are our basic needs
and that's what I'm doing right now and
I'm trying to ask myself just really
simple kind of basic questions where I
could look at my kids and if I tell them
here are the things that will never
change they'll be like yeah it makes
sense from there and we've done this
because we're a little bit further ahead
in some of those sectors that we
identified early they're not super
complicated but then what we've said is
which companies have now been
disproportionately punished
despite
basic needs that should remain
relatively and violent over the long arc
of time so I'll give you an example you
know the one of the things that this is
strained is the internet itself and
within that I think one thing that we
have realized is how misconfigured
telecom infrastructure wireless
infrastructure and the wireless
providers functionally are so let's
think about this they have physical
wireline infrastructure they have a you
know very complicated very expensive
wireless infrastructure that doesn't
really support massive massive
throughput they have incredibly
complicated very expensive back-office
ah packs to run it because they were
traditional wireline carriers that try
to morph they spend hundreds of hundreds
of millions of dollars trying to
increment aliy build capacity both in
terms of spectrum as well as satellites
and then to top all of that [ __ ] Sunday
off the cherry on top is that they have
a physical retail infrastructure that is
the only way for you to interact if you
want to switch your plan if you want to
upgrade your plan if you want to switch
carriers you know they've been they've
been resistant to e sims now you're
sitting at home and even if you wanted
to switch every carrier is thinking to
themselves
I can't run ads I can't switch because I
can't deliver a sim to these people
because the stores are closed now take
out all that dysfunction the wireless
carriers will continue to be more and
more important you know we've we've
realized that we need to have a more
resilient internet we've realized that
it needs to be somewhat more homegrown
as well we can't really know we can't
rely on hallway or Ericsson necessarily
we have to have you know internal
American products and solutions we need
to service the rural areas of the
country as well as the you know cities
cities have very different complicated
patterns of density and servicing that
are not done well I mean like you go to
a place like New York City and Verizon
is just complete [ __ ] so we know that
the outcome is but we don't know what's
the path to get there is and we have a
bunch of companies that have just gotten
decimated now then if you take that and
you overlay those dynamics in emerging
markets what you see already is a bunch
of bankruptcies so that's an example of
where we've said okay do we step in
is there a company here that we can buy
out of you know the Chilean equivalent
of chapter 11 bankruptcy here you know
chapter 7 bankruptcy and what would that
look like or you know are there are
there companies that we could get a hold
of but buying the debt and then
basically trans transforming it that's
an example we've been monitoring very
closely all sources of alternative data
so what's an example of alternative data
opentable has some incredible data Yelp
has incredible data second measure
credit card panels there's a company I
can't remember the name who we use for
footfall data TomTom and we use that to
build a complexion and what we're asking
ourselves is what does this show in
terms of patterns another thing that
we've looked at as a result of that is
in commercial real estate so I think
that commercial real estate is
fundamentally impaired now because when
you factor in just like you and I are as
productive as if you and I by the way
just think about this you had flown to
San Francisco we could not connect you
flew back but you stayed in a hotel you
had some meals blah blah blah let's say
roughly you spent three or four thousand
dollars on that business trip you and I
are creating just as much value it cost
us zero
yep so the point for you to spend five
thousand dollars of effects to generate
this asset is going to be incrementally
harder for you to justify it's going to
be more to pleasure and waste than it is
out of Mead when you factor that into
how it will flow into commercial real
estate commercial real estate is
fundamentally impaired it's it's
essentially what Tom Baraka said but in
a world where that commercial real
estate is impaired that's not going to
be completely true now there are certain
REITs
example that only serve as big-box
retailers specifically Walmart Amazon
distribution and groceries now faves on
they've seen 50% draw downs as well
because you know you throw the baby out
with the bathwater when things like this
happen and so we've been going bottoms
up in certain REITs literally looking at
property by property trying to figure
out are these things valued fairly or
reasonably the thing with this work that
I'll tell you is that it is incredibly
humbling because it is unbelievably
boring and super [ __ ] tactical I mean
you got to be a worker in moments like
this a humble worker put your hat on you
know and just grind it out and it is
excruciating ly boring numbing
time-consuming but in it is where you'll
find I think the Nuggets but that's what
we're doing we're we're prioritizing
needs we're asking ourselves what won't
change and then we're looking at things
and essentially what that leads us to is
a bunch of offline businesses or hybrid
businesses the other part of our
exercise is saying what things need to
change and all of that leads us to our
portfolio private businesses and what we
are doing there as we put out feelers
and what we've said to people is like
look we have buying capacity here we're
willing to be the buyer but we want
control and so you know I'm not
interested in putting in 15 million
dollars in a Series C or a series D
extension round but I'll buy your
business for 50 million a hundred
million two hundred million and then
I'll fund the rest of the j-curve to get
out of it if we think that that solution
is interesting and so we're looking in
healthcare we're looking at climate
change we're looking at education and
those are the three areas that we think
are going to change the fastest in this
move to resiliency so that's kind of
what we're doing but honestly dude it's
not glamorous it's super [ __ ]
tactical